forte mobilisation du personnel soignant
ce mardi 16 juin dans les yvelines au
centre hospitalier de versailles andré
mignot une centaine de professionnels
tous services confondus à des filets
suite à l'appel des syndicats qu'ils se
sont réunis devant la structure à 13h en
faisant beaucoup de bruit
on va taton récurrentes rappelé
l'importance de l'hôpital public et puis
les enjeux il ya autant de talent public
et je pense qu'on a tous étaient
conscients de cela au travers de la
crise due qu'au guide et on souhaite que
ce qui a été initié avant la crise se
poursuivent après la crise de sorte à ce
que le public soit préservé même constat
à l'hôpital de mantes-la-jolie pendant
la période du coc vide 19 le personnel
soignant estime qu'il a prouvé son
engagement
parmi leurs revendications des moyens
supplémentaires pour travailler on a
plus de pied à perfusion on a plus de 2
pousse seringue
on a plus de chaises roulantes et on
fait quoi pour travailler pour certains
collègues qui l'ont fait avec des bouts
de ficelle avec des sacs plastique en
guise de bouse qui mais qu'est ce qui a
vraiment mis en évidence la carence du
système hospitalier à l'heure actuelle
depuis 2015 on a perdu 109 lits
d'hospitalisation et près de 250 postes
est ce qu'il ya eu une modification de
son action gouvernementale absolument
pas les soignants demande également une
revalorisation de salaire
l'intersyndicale réclame 300 euros pour
tous
[Musique]
cette soignants du travail à l'hôpital
de mantes-la-jolie depuis 15 ans elle se
mobilise avec le collectif inter
hôpitaux c'est investir dans la santé
des français
l'hôpital public il est indispensable
pour le bon fonctionnement de cet état
le privé ne me fait pas le même travail
que l'hôpital public que privé
sélectionne ses patients nous on
sélectionne pas au brandt monde
les soignants attendent des réponses du
gouvernement d'autres mobilisations
devrait être organisée dans les
prochaines semaines dans les yvelines